it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr. John Gartner who is
founder of duty to warn co-editor of
Rocketman nuclear madness and the mind
of Donald Trump as many in our audience
may remember from the last time he was
on he taught in the department of
psychiatry at Johns Hopkins Medical
Center for 28 years John great to have
you back first of all thank you thanks
for having me back so listen you and I
have had over the last year a couple of
conversations about what some perceive
to be a cognitive decline of the
President of the United States the term
pre dementia state has been used by you
and other mental health professionals
this has become extraordinarily
polarizing at this point where you have
part of the mental health community
feeling very confident that the
president is experiencing noticeable
marked cognitive decline and that more
needs to be done in order to examine
that and on the other side you have
individuals who believe that any mention
of this is a conspiracy theory
completely without merit or evidence and
its really become polarizing even within
certain aspects of the mental health
community so let's kind of take a step
back well you know uestions those
critics okay is there any amount of
evidence is there any fact or any
clinical sign or any amount of evidence
that would suggest to a rational
objective person that he is suffering
from serious mental decline and needs to
be evaluated in other words it seems
like this is sort of a parallel to
what's going on in the political world
right with the malla report it's like no
matter how many facts you have there are
people who will spin it the other way
which then distracts you from an
objective evaluation of the facts you
know this process about looking at his
mental decline as you say began a year
ago so a year ago this time a number of
articles came out one from Ford Vox a
neurologist one from David Hamblin a
medical doctor who's an editor at the
Atlantic one from Sharon Begley in stat
and all three of them made the same
point a year ago that they were noticing
a noticeable decline when comparing
Donald Trump to his own baseline so if
you and this is one of the most
reliable indicators of organic mental
deterioration is when someone gets worse
than their own normal functioning they
they deteriorate from their own baseline
so they noticed deterioration in various
formal factors his vocabulary was
diminished the complexity of his
sentences and his ability to complete a
sentence was diminished there's a
paucity of thought there was an increase
in repetition and filler words and and
and and repetition and all of those are
signs that someone might be cognitively
declining from their earlier state and
we wrote a lot and we wrote enough few
op eds about it and we sent a letter to
Ronnie Jackson asking him to do a
neurological exam or screener which he
did and at that point Trump passed and
there was some debate about what did
that mean that he passed so it meant
that he wasn't in a state of full-blown
dementia because he could for example
recognize a camel he could repeat three
numbers backward he could draw clock it
didn't mean that he wasn't in some state
of pre dementia or cognitive decline
from his own baseline but what we said
at that time what we predicted is if he
really does have organic cognitive
decline it will get worse that was the
prediction if our if our fears about the
potential diagnosis were true that he
would deteriorate even further from that
point so now here we are one year later
and I'm here to report that he has
deteriorated he has gotten worse to the
point where now I think the question is
not does he have pre dementia I think
the question is does he have dementia
and if so at what stage is it so in the
a second I want to get to how we would
evaluate that but so to just admit
clarify and make sure we all understand
what you're saying
individually if someone repeats a word
or type of word frequently if someone
miss States for example that their
father was born in Germany when their
father was born in the United States or
whatever individually that in and of
itself may not be notable but when
comparing Donald Trump now to Donald
Trump
two five and twenty years ago for which
there's significant audio-visual record
that's the comparison that you believe
is particularly important to pay
attention to well actually that's what
we said a year ago I'm now saying
something even more serious now that if
you say your father was born in Germany
and it's your grandfather that was born
in Germany that is a sign of illness but
that is something that we see in people
who have dementia so we have progressed
beyond the point the Donald Trump is
simply worse than his own baseline to
the point where he is now showing
concrete signs of dementia itself and
let me give you some specific examples
one is what you just mentioned so yes
he's had problems with memory he's
gotten people's names wrong very
frequently there are videos on the son
you know the online you could see we
make fun of him for getting names wrong
Tim Apple was the one that you know it's
most recently in the news but now we're
seeing a level of deterioration of
memory that's more clinical for example
in fire and fury it's reported that he
seemed to not recognize old friends at
mar-a-lago and this symptom of saying
that his father was born in Germany said
of three times when it's his grandfather
that was born in Germany that reminded
me a lot of my uncle who recently died
of Alzheimer's that two months before he
had to go into the nursing home he was
agitated one day and he cried out for me
he said call John he's a rich lawyer
he'll know what to do well I'm not a
lawyer my father was a lawyer so he
confused me and my father he kind of
mashed us into one person so this mixing
of the generations are mixing people in
your family into one person that's
something that we see clinically in
people that are actually in a state of
dementia and may even be unable to live
independently and need to go to a
nursing home in other words what I'm
saying is before when we brought this
issue up we were talking about a decline
from his own baseline now we're seeing
signs of a more frank dementia quite
possibly the other formal signs that
we're seeing or something or something
called para phages so there's two types
of para phases one is called a semantic
para phase where you use the wrong word
for example when he said now we have to
look
to the oranges of the mauler
investigation right where it began from
the oranges the oranges of the
investigated three times and when he
said where the investigation began you
could tell he was trying to modify the
word oranges by clarifying you know
where the where it began because he
could tell he somehow vaguely knew he
wasn't reaching the right word but he
didn't quite have an awareness that he
didn't have the right word if you know
what I'm saying
so we needed to clarify what he meant by
oranges but he said it three times in a
row that's a semantic power feature
where you literally just use the wrong
word for what you're trying to say and
then there's something called a phonetic
para fascia where you use something that
is not a word at all not an English word
whatsoever but it's phonetically sounds
like the word you're trying to say so
when he for example was introducing
Benjamin Netanyahu called him bettin
Yahoo you know he called Peninsula
Peninsula you know a lot of attention
was given to when he's trying to say
anonymous he was saying animus animus
trying to say anonymous he says capsicum
for capsule there's if you there's
actually a great video online maybe you
can show it later in the show or people
can go online and see it for themselves
from the daily show it's two and a half
minutes of these mispronunciations sort
of strung together and it's meant to be
humorous I guess from the daily show but
it's actually quite clinically
significant what I'm trying to say is
neurologically intact people don't do
this period what would I know don't do
this what I've been making the point of
is I'm not a mental health professional
nor a neurologist although some people
thought that I was a neurologist based
on a very strange episode a year ago but
that's maybe a story for another day
I've been saying it wouldn't be funny
this wouldn't be funny right like we're
not we're whatever The Daily Show is
doing we're not making fun of the
possibility that someone is experiencing
cognitive decline if indeed this is
what's going on it needs to be taken
seriously and it needs to be examined
and that's sort of the next question I
have for you which is that in your USA
Today op-ed you say the identifying a
llama or whatever it was and saying
three numbers and identifying the city
in which this test was administered the
Montreal cognitive assessment
but that's not really what we need here
what what is it that we need and what
would a proper assessment look like if
Donald Trump were your father you would
run not walk to the neurologist for an
evaluation these kinds of really
shocking signs would galvanize you to a
state of emergency basically to bring
him for a full-blown neuropsychological
evaluation and that's what we called for
a year ago and that's what we're calling
for in this op-ed but now it's really at
an emergent level it's not just a oh
he's kind of missing a step or he's not
what he used to be no now he's showing
Frank signs of dementia I mean this is
like the emperor's new clothes that's
what I'm saying like what how much would
he need to be babbling before people
would acknowledge these aren't English
words that he's speaking and what would
a full-blown evaluation look like in
practice how long does it take what sort
of things are part of that ya know it
takes several hours it's a battery of
tests it's a very serious in thorough
evaluation and you would do nothing less
for your relative I mean someone on
Medicaid would would dr. would make sure
that they got approval for that kind of
an evaluation if they were showing these
kinds of serious signs and symptoms so
these are not just signs that he's
deteriorated these are actual clinical
signs that are suggestive of you know
when people have phonetic para phages
that's considered a sign of the
intermediate to severe stage of the
illness and what else is I mean just for
people who don't don't understand what
types of questions and tests and exams
are part of this multi hour examination
what do you ask the subject to do well
it's it well first of all I have to say
I'm not a neuropsychologist although
I've done some neuropsychological
research and I so I don't administer
these exams but it's a it is a battery
of exams and maybe a dozen different
tasks you might ask them to do but it's
tasks having to do with memory
comprehension vocabulary it's fairly
comprehensive and it by the way we also
see these the
dementia affects people in ways other
than simply language for example there's
some videotape that we've seen of him
seeming to be disoriented and wandering
I think you've probably seen that
videotape where he walks past his limo
yeah and people have to direct him back
to the limo there was a place when he
was on stage and Poland and he was just
wandering around the stage as if you
just didn't know why he was there and
people had gained him I mean I think he
walked offstage on what he did so this
is the kind of thing that you know again
people who are neurologically intact
don't wander you know these are now
starting to be like hardcore kinds of
signs you know since I've written this
I've had maybe 30 or 40 or 50 people
write me saying oh my god I'm seeing a
Donald Trump signs that I saw and my
mother or my wife or my father when he
was dying of dementia people even
mentioned a kind of confused blank look
on his face which you may have noticed
seen that sometimes where he just seems
sort of like he doesn't know where
what's going on now that's not something
that you can quantify in a neurological
exam but it's one of those kind of like
things that takes you aback and go whoa
when I've seen that look before it's
been in someone's face whereas dementia
so all these people who have had
personal experience I've had geriatric
nurses right now I've had doctors write
me who were geriatric gerontologist
saying this is what I deal with every
single day of my life and this is what
I'm observing in the president and the
last thing I want to touch on you know a
year ago you talked about what we might
see in the next year if this goes in the
direction you believe it may be going
what should we be looking for in the
year to to come and of course the
trajectory for any individual can be
different whether or not you're talking
about dementia just as people age but
what would you be paying particular
attention to well I think we're going to
see further deterioration in his
language and in fact there is a psyche
of psychologist at University of
Pittsburgh led by Mark Koo Tosh that did
a formal study of his verbalizations and
they found that over the last seven
years he's increased in using sort of
nonsense filler words like mum which is
one of the
diminished neurological functioning I'm
actually going to be working with him
we're least talking about doing some
more formal studies of his
verbalizations so we can actually
quantify these things in a more
scientific way his paper was a
peer-reviewed journal that appeared in a
site psychological journal so one thing
is we will see more deterioration but
more deterioration is memory more
disorientation more nonsense words more
use of the wrong words more more
deterioration in his train of thought
one of the things we see is that he's he
used to speak in Polish paragraphs now
he can hardly finish a sentence without
D railing into a non sequitur it's
something we call tangential speech and
to individual speech is also a sign of
dementia so we're going to see more
fragmentation more chaotic sort of crazy
speeches where he just seems to be R
from one irrelevance e to another but
here's the other thing
it also affects people's judgement their
impulsivity their reality testing and
their sort of capacity to function in
every respect so what we have here is we
haven't even talked about the severe
personality disorder which is what we
were talking about for the first two
years but now we have someone with a
severe personality disorder who may also
have dementia this is literally the
worst case scenario if you were to
invent the worst case scenario
imaginable it couldn't be worse than
what we're talking about right now
someone with a severe personality
disorder who's now cognitively
potentially becoming demented I mean who
has the nuclear codes there's absolutely
no way that he has the capacity to if
this is the case if it's what it appears
to what it appears to be this is someone
whose potential for making catastrophic
errors is extremely high so one of the
manifestations might be just him doing
something crazy and destructive that
could kill millions of people we will be
eagerly awaiting those studies that you
are going to be working on including the
linguistic analysis dr. John Gartner
founder of duty to warn co-editor of
Rocketman taught in the department of
psychiatry at Johns Hopkins Medical
Center for 28 years John always great to
talk to you
yeah always great to talk to you